cbs news senior political analyst and 60
minutes correspondent john dickerson
joins us now
john good morning to you listen we're
going to spend a lot of time
in the next 24 hours talking about how
did we get here as a country this is
going to be one of those days that you
will always remember where you were
and what you were doing as you sat and
watched it but i have a better q i have
another question
who are we john as a people we watched
police officers taking selfies and don't
call them protesters
with these rioters we saw police opening
barricades for these people to come
through
who are we and how did we get here
well uh who are we as a country will be
determined
in the coming days and in the ways in
which people respond to this there's an
opportunity for leadership here just as
there's been an opportunity
at crisis moments uh over the last many
years
in this country and so people who are in
leadership need to step
up but we'll see if they do there have
been a lot of people who have not
stepped up and that's part of the reason
we are where we are the president is the
obviously
most recent actor who inspired these
events
he fed his supporters lies for months
he called them to washington his son and
rudy giuliani whipped them up and then
the president said go march down to the
capitol and don't be weak
but the members of the president's party
who watched all of this
for years and made excuses for the
president's behavior who watched
traditions and norms be eroded
we'll watch the very nature of truth be
assaulted
bear responsibility for this as well and
as they see the president continue to
lie about what happened in the election
and say nothing they're committing the
same
mistake they did you'll remember on
election day gail when you and i were
together
and i used that weird phrase about
burning the furniture of democracy
what i was trying to say is if you allow
the the idea that the president was
pushing which is that the proper
election process was somehow sinister if
you allow that to fester
what will happen is you will end up
destroying the thing that the entire
democracy
relies on well two months later that's
what we saw yesterday john we're still
in a very
tentative position though because
president trump has 14 days still
in the white house he's incited a riot
he reportedly resisted calling in the
national guard
he hasn't condemned the violence he's
still even though he says he's committed
to an orderly transition is spewing lies
about an election
he lost and it wasn't even close so what
do you do in these 14 days to keep order
in the country
well it's a it's an excellent question
and we've there's obviously the
reporting about the 25th
amendment and invoking that and
basically stripping his power from him
um but i'm not sure it's a it's a uh
a delicate remaining 14 days and people
in leadership
uh need to constantly send a message
of uh of unity and calm but the
president
even though he's saying he's committed
to a peaceful transfer of power when he
continues to put the thorn in the shoe
by saying the election was stolen and
not having someone
stand up and say that is a lie you're
leaving the basis the poison is still
there john dickerson thank you so much
for being with us this morning we have
more to come